mucho antes del plazo establecido.
Eso demuestra que esta especie de la humanidad
puede lograr avances extraordinarios
si realmente actúa en conjunto y se esfuerza mucho.
Pero si tuviera que decirlo en pocas palabras, actualmente,
siento que la globalización
nos ha tomado por sorpresa,
y hemos respondido con lentitud.
Si miramos los efectos negativos de la globalización,
a veces realmente parece ser abrumadora.
Frente a los grandes desafíos que enfrentamos hoy,
como el cambio climático y los derechos humanos
la demografía, el terrorismo y las pandemias,
el narcotráfico y la esclavitud humana,
la pérdida de especies, y podría seguir,
no estamos haciendo un gran avance
ante gran cantidad de esos desafíos.
Por eso, en pocas palabras, ese es el desafío
que enfrentamos hoy
en este punto interesante de la historia.
Eso es claramente lo que tenemos que hacer a continuación.
De algún modo tenemos que actuar juntos
y descubrir cómo globalizar
mejor las soluciones
para no ser solo una especie
víctima de la globalización de los problemas.
¿Por qué avanzamos tan lentamente?
¿Cuál es la razón?
Bueno, hay, claro, varias razones,
pero quizá la razón principal
es que como especie aún estamos organizados
de la misma manera que
hace 200 o 300 años.
Queda una superpotencia en el planeta
y somos los 7000 millones de personas,
los 7000 millones que causamos estos problemas,
los mismos 7000 millones, por cierto,
que los resolveremos.
¿Pero cómo nos organizamos los 7000 millones?
Nos organizamos en 200 o más naciones,
y las naciones tienen gobiernos
que hacen leyes
que nos hacen comportar de cierta manera.
Y es un sistema bastante eficiente,
pero el problema es que la redacción de esas leyes
y la forma de pensar de los gobiernos
es totalmente errónea para la solución de problemas globales,
porque todo eso mira hacia adentro.
Los políticos que elegimos
y los que no elegimos, en conjunto,
piensan en lo microscópico.
No tienen mentes telescópicas.
Miran hacia adentro. Fingen, se comportan,
como si creyeran que cada país es una isla
que existe muy feliz, independiente
de todos los otros
en su propio y pequeño planeta
en su propio y pequeño sistema solar.
Este es el problema:
los países compiten unos contra otros,
los países luchan unos contra otros.
Esta semana, como cualquier semana que miren,
encontrarán personas que tratan de matarse unos a otros de país a país
y, si no pasa eso,
hay una competencia entre países,
cada uno tratando de maltratar al otro.
Claramente no es una buena configuración.
Claramente tenemos que cambiarla.
Claramente tenemos que encontrar la forma
de alentar a los países a empezar a trabajar juntos
un poquito mejor.
¿Y por qué no lo harán?
¿Por qué nuestros líderes todavía siguen mirando hacia adentro?
Bueno, la primera razón y la más obvia
es porque nosotros se lo pedimos.
Les decimos que hagan eso.
Cuando elegimos gobiernos,
o cuando toleramos gobiernos no electos,
efectivamente les decimos que queremos
que le den a nuestro país
determinadas cosas.
Queremos prosperidad,
crecimiento, competitividad, transparencia, justicia
y todo eso.
Por eso, a menos que empecemos a pedirles
que piensen hacia afuera un poquito más,
que consideren los problemas globales que tendremos
si no empezamos a pensar en ellos,
entonces difícilmente podamos culparlos
si siguen mirando hacia adentro,
si todavía miran lo microscópico
en vez de mirar lo telescópico.
Esa es la primera razón por la que las cosas no cambian.
La segunda razón es que estos gobiernos,
como el resto de nosotros,
son psicópatas culturales.
Yo no quiero ser grosero,
pero ya saben lo que es un psicópata.
Un psicópata es una persona que
desafortunadamente para él o ella,
no puede lograr empatía
con otros seres humanos.
Cuando miran alrededor
no ven a otros seres humanos
con vidas profundas, ricas, tridimensionales,
con objetivos y ambiciones.
Ven en cambio recortes de cartón,
es algo muy triste y solitario,
y es muy poco frecuente, afortunadamente.
Pero, en realidad, ¿no somos la mayoría
no tan buenos en empatía?
Claro, somos buenos en empatía
para tratar con personas
que se nos parecen
que caminan, comen y rezan
como nosotros,
pero si se trata de personas que no lo hacen así,
que no se visten como nosotros,
que no rezan como nosotros,
que no hablan como nosotros,
¿no tendemos también a verlos
levemente como recortes de cartón?
Es una pregunta que tenemos que hacernos.
Pienso que tenemos que vigilar esto constantemente.
¿Somos nosotros y nuestros políticos en cierto punto
psicópatas culturales?
La tercera razón no es muy digna de mención
por ser muy tonta,
pero hay una creencia en los gobiernos
de que la agenda local
y la agenda internacional
son incompatibles y siempre lo serán.
Esto no tiene sentido.
En mi trabajo diario soy asesor de política.
He pasado los últimos 15 años
asesorando a gobiernos de todo el mundo,
y en todo ese tiempo nunca he visto
un solo problema de política local
que no pueda ser resuelto más imaginativamente
con más eficiencia y rapidez
que tratándolo como un problema internacional,
mirando el contexto internacional,
comparando con lo que han hecho otros,
incluyendo a otros, trabajando en el ámbito externo
en vez de hacerlo en el interno.
Teniendo en cuenta todo eso podrán decir:
¿Por qué entonces no funciona?
¿Por qué no podemos hacer cambiar a nuestros políticos?
¿Por qué no se lo pedimos?
Bueno, yo como muchos, paso mucho tiempo quejándome
de lo difícil que es hacer que la gente cambie,
y no creo que tengamos que preocuparnos por eso.
Pienso que deberíamos aceptar
que pertenecemos a una especie inherentemente conservadora.
No nos gusta el cambio.
Es así por razones evolutivas muy sensatas.
Probablemente no estaríamos aquí hoy
de no haber resistido tanto el cambio.
Es muy simple: Hace miles de años,
descubrimos que si continuábamos
haciendo las mismas cosas no moriríamos,
porque las cosas que hicimos antes
por definición no nos mataron,
y por lo tanto si seguíamos haciendo eso,
estaríamos bien,
y era muy sensato no hacer nada nuevo,
porque podría matarnos.
Pero claro, hay excepciones.
De lo contrario, nunca llegaríamos a ninguna parte.
Y una de las excepciones, la excepción interesante,
es cuando podemos mostrarle a las personas
que puede haber un poco de interés propio
en dar ese salto de fe
y cambiar un poco.
Hemos pasado gran parte de los últimos 10 o 15 años
tratando de descubrir cuál podría ser ese interés propio
que pudiera alentar tanto a políticos
como a empresas y a la población en general,
a todos nosotros, a pensar un poco más hacia afuera,
a pensar en el panorama general,
no siempre mirar hacia adentro, y a veces mirar hacia afuera.
Y fue entonces que descubrí
algo bastante importante.
En 2005 lancé un estudio
llamado Índice de Marca País.
Es un estudio a muy gran escala que encuesta
a una muestra muy grande de la población mundial,
una muestra que representa a un 70 %
de la población del planeta,
y le empecé a hacer una serie de preguntas
sobre cómo perciben a otros países.
Y el Índice de Marca País con los años
se ha convertido en una enorme base de datos.
Tiene unas 200 000 millones de entradas
que siguen la opinión de la gente común sobre otros países
y por qué.
¿Por qué hago esto? Bueno, porque a los gobiernos que aconsejo
les interesa mucho saber
cómo los ven.
Saben, en parte porque
yo los he alentado a darse cuenta,
que los países dependen
enormemente de su reputación
para sobrevivir y prosperar en el mundo.
Si un país tiene una gran imagen positiva,
como Alemania, Suecia o Suiza,
todo es fácil y todo es barato.
Uno recibe más turistas, y tiene más inversores.
Uno vende sus productos más caros.
Por el contrario, si uno tiene un país
con una imagen muy débil o muy negativa,
todo es difícil y todo es caro.
Entonces los gobiernos se preocupan desesperadamente
por la imagen del país,
porque marca una diferencia directa
en el dinero que pueden ganar,
y eso es lo que le han prometido a sus poblaciones
que harán.
Por eso hace un par de años decidí tomarme
un tiempo y hablar con esa base de datos gigante
y preguntarle
¿por qué algunas personas prefieren a un país
más que a otro?
Y la respuesta que me dio esa base de datos
me dejó anonadado.
Fue 6,8.
No tengo tiempo para explicarlo en detalle.
Básicamente me dijo...
(Risas) (Aplausos)
que preferimos a los países buenos.
No admiramos a los países principalmente porque sean ricos
porque sean poderosos, porque sean exitosos,
porque sean modernos, porque sean avanzados en tecnología.
Admiramos principalmente a los países buenos.
¿Qué queremos decir con 'buenos'?
Queremos decir países que parecen contribuir
en algo al mundo en que vivimos,
países que en realidad hacen al mundo más seguro
o mejor o más rico o más justo.
Esos son los países que nos gustan.
Este es un descubrimiento de importancia significativa
—ven hacia dónde voy—
porque cierra el círculo.
Ahora puedo decir, lo hago a menudo, a cualquier gobierno,
para que te vaya bien tienes que hacer el bien.
Si quieres vender más productos,
si quieres recibir más inversiones,
si quieres ser más competitivo,
tienes que comportarte,
porque de ese modo las personas te respetarán
y harán negocios contigo,
y por lo tanto, cuanto más colabores
más competitivo serás.
Este es un descubrimiento bastante importante
y ni bien lo descubrí
sentí que venía un nuevo índice.
Juro que cuanto más viejo me pongo, más simples son mis ideas,
cada vez más infantiles.
Este es el Índice de País Bueno,
y hace lo que dice en la etiqueta.
Mide, o intenta medir,
exactamente cuánto contribuye cada país de la Tierra
no a su propia población sino al resto de la humanidad.
Curiosamente, nadie había pensado nunca
en medir esto antes.
Por eso mi colega, el Dr. Robert Govers y yo, pasamos
gran parte de los últimos dos años,
junto a gran cantidad de personas muy serias e inteligentes,
consolidando todos los datos confiables del mundo
que pudimos encontrar sobre lo que dan los países
al mundo.
Estarán esperando que les diga quiénes están en la cima.
Y se los diré
pero primero quiero contarles
precisamente qué quiero decir
cuando digo país bueno.
No me refiero a moralmente bueno.
Cuando digo que el País X
es el país más bueno de la Tierra
digo el más bueno, no el mejor.
El mejor es algo distinto.
Cuando uno habla de un país bueno,
puede ser bueno, más bueno o el más bueno.
No es lo mismo que bueno, mejor y el mejor.
Este es simplemente un país que da más
a la humanidad que cualquier otro país.
No hablo de cómo se comportan localmente
porque eso se mide en otros lados.
Y el ganador es:
Irlanda.
(Aplausos)
Según estos datos,
ningún país de la Tierra, por habitante,
por dólar de PBI, contribuye más
al mundo en el que vivimos que Irlanda.
¿Qué significa esto?
Significa que cuando vamos a dormir por la noche
todos, en los últimos 15 segundos antes de conciliar el sueño,
nuestro último pensamiento debería ser
me alegro de que exista Irlanda.
(Risas)
Y eso... (Aplausos)
en lo profundo de una recesión económica muy grave
pienso que da una lección realmente muy importante
el hecho de recordar las obligaciones internacionales
mientras tratas de reconstruir tu economía,
es algo importante.
Finlandia está ubicada casi igual.
La única razón por la que está debajo de Irlanda
es porque su puntuación más baja está por debajo de la más baja de Irlanda.
Lo otro que notarán en los 10 primeros
es, claro, son todos, salvo Nueva Zelanda,
países de Europa occidental.
Todos son ricos.
Esto me deprimió
porque una de las cosas que no quería
descubrir con este índice
era la providencia de los países ricos
que ayudan a los países pobres.
No tiene que ver con esto.
Y de hecho, si miramos más abajo en la lista,
no tengo la diapositiva aquí, verán
algo que, de hecho, me puso muy feliz:
Kenia está entre los 30 primeros,
y eso demuestra algo muy, muy importante.
No se trata de dinero.
Tiene que ver con la actitud.
Tiene que ver con la cultura.
Tiene que ver con un gobierno y unas personas que se ocupan
del resto del mundo
y tienen la imaginación y el coraje
y piensan hacia afuera en vez de solo pensar en forma egoísta.
Pasaré rápido las otras diapositivas
para que puedan ver algunos países más abajo en la lista.
Alemania está 13, EE.UU. 21,
México 66,
y luego tenemos algunos grandes países en desarrollo
como Rusia 95, China 107.
Que países como China, Rusia e India
estén abajo en la misma parte del índice,
bueno, en cierta forma no sorprende.
Han pasado mucho tiempo
en las últimas décadas construyendo su propia economía,
construyendo su propia sociedad y su propia política,
pero es de esperar
que en la segunda fase de su crecimiento
miren un poco más hacia afuera
que en la primera fase.
Y luego pueden analizar cada país
en términos de los datos reales que los constituyen.
Les permitiré que lo hagan.
A partir de la medianoche estará en goodcountry.org,
y pueden mirar su país.
Pueden llegar hasta el nivel de los datos individuales.
Este es el Índice de País Bueno.
¿Para qué está?
Bueno, está porque quiero tratar
de introducir esta palabra
o reintroducir esta palabra al discurso.
Ya he escuchado demasiado sobre países competitivos.
Ya he escuchado demasiado sobre
países prósperos, ricos, que crecen rápidamente.
He escuchado demasiado sobre países felices
porque al final eso sigue siendo egoísta.
Eso sigue siendo sobre nosotros,
y si seguimos pensando en nosotros,
estamos en un problema muy profundo.
Pienso que sabemos sobre qué
queremos escuchar.
Queremos escuchar sobre países buenos,
por eso quiero pedirles un favor.
No pido mucho.
Es algo que puede resultar fácil de hacer
y que incluso podrían encontrar agradable
e incluso útil,
y es empezar a usar la palabra "bueno"
en este contexto.
Cuando piensen en su propio país,
cuando piensen en los países de otros,
cuando piensen en las empresas,
cuando hablen del mundo en el que vivimos hoy,
empiecen a usar esa palabra
en el modo en que les conté esta tarde.
No bueno, lo opuesto a malo,
porque esa es una discusión interminable.
Bueno, lo opuesto a egoísta,
bueno como país que piensa en todos nosotros.
Eso es lo que me gustaría que hagan,
y me gustaría que lo usen como una tabla
para golpear a sus políticos.
Cuando los eligen, cuando los reeligen,
cuando los votan, cuando escuchan
lo que les ofrecen,
usen esa palabra, "bueno",
y pregúntense:
"¿Esto es lo que haría un buen país?"
Y si la respuesta es no, sospechen.
Pregúntense, ¿es el comportamiento
de mi país?
Quiero pertenecer a un país
cuyo gobierno, en mi nombre,
hace cosas como esas?
O, por otro lado,
prefiero la idea de caminar por el mundo
con la cabeza en alto pensando: "Sí,
siento orgullo de pertenecer a un país bueno".
Y todos les darán la bienvenida.
Y todos en los últimos 15 segundos
antes de conciliar el sueño por la noche dirán:
"Dios, estoy feliz de que el país de esta persona exista".
En última instancia, eso, pienso,
es lo que generará el cambio.
La palabra "bueno",
el número 6,8
y el descubrimiento subyacente
cambiaron mi vida.
Pienso que puede cambiar sus vidas,
y pienso que podemos usarlo para cambiar
el comportamiento de nuestros políticos y empresas
y, al hacerlo, podemos cambiar el mundo.
Empecé a pensar muy diferente sobre
mi propio país al pensar en estas cosas.
Solía pensar que quería vivir en un país rico,
y luego que quería vivir en un país feliz,
pero empecé a darme cuenta de que eso no es suficiente.
No quiero vivir en un país rico.
No quiero vivir en un país que crece rápido
o que es competitivo.
Quiero vivir en un país bueno,
y espero que Uds. también.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)